welcome to the heavy spoilers show you
now locked into the channel where we
break down all the latest movies games
TV shows and comics throughout this
video we're going to be discussing the
real-life story that inspired the new
horror the lighthouse the Flannan Isles
appearance is one of the biggest
unsolved mysteries of the past 200 years
and throughout this video we'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the story as well as the
theories behind what really happened
there will be some spoilers in regards
to the lighthouse here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the movie yet and
don't want some of the aspects ruined
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now we won't be spoiling the ending
but there are some plot points here that
we'll be going over so if you don't want
to go in with any prior knowledge then
this is your last chance to back out
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
Flannan Isles appearances the film the
lighthouse follows two lighthouse
watchmen known as Winslow and Wake the
latter of whom begins to turn on the
former due to losing his grip on reality
and gaining paranoia that makes him
begin to take a dark path whilst the
events that happened in the movie seem
very extreme they're actually a lot
closer to the real-life events than you
may think
and the truth is definitely a lot
stranger than fiction the real-life
story of the lighthouse starts at the
beginning of the prior century in the
year 1900 and takes place on plan'n Isle
Flannan Isles is located in the Outer
Hebrides off the west coast of Scotland
and this remote island was a central
pillar of a sea trade in the area
the lighthouse guided ships through the
night from crashing into perilous rocks
and due to its importance it required
three people to mana at all times this
included Thomas Marshall James ducat and
Donald MacArthur who were all placed on
the island over the December to watch
over the isle and make sure that the
upkeep of the lighthouse was maintained
all men were thought to be loyal
hard-working people that put duty above
all else and took pride in their work a
lot of trust had been put in them to man
the station and no one would ever
believe that they would flee from their
post no matter what weather conditions
there may be however on the 15th of
December 19
hundred the steamer arched or noted that
the light was not in operation and when
they docked three days later they passed
this information on to the northern
Lighthouse Board though this was unusual
it was not uncommon for the time
especially due to the electrical upkeep
that was required on such a station and
the board didn't attempt to send out a
relief vessel until two days later as
was scheduled however due to poor
weather conditions the boat did not
actually reach the island until the 26th
of December upon arrival the crew of the
relief vessel found that the Flagstaff
had no flag and that all of the
provision boxes had been left at the
dock more worrying than this though was
the absence of the lighthouse keepers
who had not emerged to welcome them to
shore the captain of the relief vessel
tried to flag them with both a flare and
the ship's whistle but still no one
emerged to see them from here a boat was
launched with a relief keeper Joseph
more of both man man the island in
rotation he found the gate and door to
the compound locked all beds unmade and
every [ __ ] stopped he returned to the
landing stage to inform the relief
vessel and joined by a more substantial
crew he journeyed back to the station to
find a final entry in the lighthouse log
saying that due to weather conditions
they had problems on the island
throughout the previous week however
everything in the station seemed fine
untouched except for one single chair
which was upturned and a half-eaten meal
which still lay on the table almost as
if something terrible had happened
during it a coat was still hanging up as
well which meant that one person had
left the lighthouse without it the 1912
ballad Flannan Isles Red Wilson Gibson
refers to the conditions that the
sailors met upon landing and the lyrics
are as follows
yet as we crowded through the door we
only saw a table spread but dinner meat
and cheese and bread but all untouched
and no one there as though when they sat
down to eat yeah they could even taste
alarm had come and they in haste had
risen and left their bread and meat for
at the table had a chair they tumbled on
the floor men scoured every inch of the
island unable to find anything out of
place except for the West landing which
seemed to be damaged by storms a box had
broken
its contents were about the island with
an iron railway pulled out the concrete
and a ton rock that had been moved from
its usual location well as this gave an
indication that it could have been the
spot that the lives of the keepers ended
at the damage was actually mentioned in
the log long before the final entry and
thus it could not have led to their
disappearance their bodies were never
found it nor a trace of what happened to
them and on the 29th of December the
northern Lighthouse Board investigation
launched an inquiry their examination of
the logbook revealed the very unusual
entries such as one by Thomas Marshall
which read severe winds the like of
which I have never seen before in 20
years
James is being very quiet and Donald has
been crying further entries also said
that the men had been praying and
whatever happened it's clear that they
were very fearful for their lives what's
strange about this is that all the men
were experienced lighthouse keepers who
are due to the station's location which
was 150 feet above sea level would have
been safe from harm
what's even more alarming is that there
were no reports of storms in the area
that week and the final entry in the
journal actually read storm ended c-calm
god is overall meaning that at least
from their perspective it had ended
whilst the investigation could not find
any evidence on the island they
summarized that MacArthur who was
required to stay behind in all
operations to man the lighthouse watched
for danger as the other two tried to
moor a loose box and he saw incoming
waves after running down and trying to
warn his colleagues of the danger he was
too late and they were all swept aside
by one giant wave this will explain the
overturned chair coat that still
remained hanging and milla had been
placed out however it doesn't really
clear up why the door and gate were
locked as MacArthur would have had to
stop to carry out both of these tasks
thus meaning that he rushed to get
outside and then took his time making
sure that everything was closed up
properly further investigations began to
paint the lighthouse occupies themselves
as the main causes behind the
disappearances with one report alleging
that MacArthur who was renowned for his
short temper may have become volatile
and lashed out at one of the many at the
edge of a cliff
the other one rushed over to break up
the fight and caused all three to fall
to their death
it's another theory is that MacArthur
went insane attacked the men during
their mealtime and left the lighthouse
throwing their bodies into the sea he
then went back to lock everything up and
jumped over the cliff to his own death
this would explain why he didn't take
his coat and why the chair and Miu were
placed at the scene however there are
also more paranormal theories which
range from all manner of things horror
of Fang rock uses the incident as an
inspiration and says that they may have
been abducted by aliens some believe
that a giant serpent or bird attacked
the island whilst others theorized that
they had been taken away by foreign
spies some believe that they faked their
own deaths in order to start a new life
and the 2018 movie the vanishing States
that the men accidentally ended up
killing a man who drifted ashore and
covered this up lying about the weather
conditions in order to mask their
disappearances and steal his precious
cargo none of these explanations thou
have ever brought any comfort to the
families left behind by the keepers and
James ducat left a widow and four
children while stun on the Cathar left
behind a widow and two their
disappearances have cast a long shadow
over light housekeeping for 100 years
and it is unlikely that we will get to
the bottom of exactly what happened no
doubt the theories will continue to come
from whoever hears about the tale but as
of yet we have no real evidence that
confirms anything this is why the
lighthouse is such a fascinating film it
is massively open to interpretation and
many of the events that have been in it
can be seen as part of the characters
imaginations or something supernatural
that is happening to them
the Flannan lighthouse stands a strong
reminder that the world is a very
strange place and the lighthouse
exemplifies this perfectly in every
single aspect it's why it's one of my
favorite horror movies of the last
decade and if you haven't seen it yet
and this video has piqued your interest
then I highly recommend that you seek it
out and give it a try the acting is
superb and there's a real atmosphere to
the entire piece that makes it an
instant classic and definitely worth
checking out if you're a fan of horror
movies that have a dark sense of humor
now obviously I loved hear your thoughts
on the Flannan lighthouse disappearance
and if you have any theories and make
sure you leave them in the comments
section below
if you enjoy this video then please give
it a thumbs
and don't forget to check out my full
ending explained breakdown of the
lighthouse which would be linked at the
end I go over everything you need to
know about the film and give my
interpretation on it so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more or have any additional questions
about the movie if you want to come chat
to me after the video then make sure you
follow me in twitter at definition
whitey or head over to my discord server
which would be linked in the description
below those are the best ways to keep up
to date with all the latest videos and
the channel so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the Marvel phase 3 part 1
box set and blu-ray which contains Civil
War Doctor Strange homecoming Ragnarok
and more and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning it's like the
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
the lighthouse in the comments section
below the winners gonna be chosen on the
15th of November and the set will be
shipped there from then to ever gets the
prize it's the best of luck that
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]